because i didn't reject him because i
wasn't attracted to him i thought he was
very attractive i rejected him because
he he was like
too much of a [ __ ] so he might have
weakness from you
and so and like three and he'd been just
pursuing me for like years at that point
so i was like oh and maybe he actually
like likes me you know what i mean
because it's been like three years okay
that's a long time to talk about longer
it's a long game to play was it worth it
was the whole reputation
was the this whole his whole reputation
did live up to the reputation of being a
[ __ ]
nothing happened like that with like no
i mean it ended for um different reasons
but
but that wasn't why like it didn't work
out but
um
yeah i guess that like like but i
rejected him for a different reason it
wasn't because i wasn't attracted to him
okay that's not like your typical male
friend you know what about like have you
had a female friend that you've known as
a friend and then you've changed men
don't put women in friend zones
yes
yes yes they yes they yes they do yes
they do listen now listen listen yes
they do they just sleep with them
and you're no longer interested in
having a casual relationship with her
but you're on good terms yeah she's a
favorite she's a friend now isn't she
yeah it's different and she's also
casual sex
no but you're no longer having casual
sex they're not stopped for some reason
and you're still you're still amicable
that's a female friend yeah that that
that that they're kind of close that
happens that can happen of a guy but the
difference is opposite of women so you
will put a fred guy in a friendzone
without [ __ ] him first
wait okay
so what are the categories that you guys
put women in friends with benefits
friends benefit like and then like
possible relationship and that's it and
then that's why whoa
someone that you'd want to have kids
with and then like friends with benefits
and then let's say like wifey like what
is wifey category what do you mean how
do you get from friends with benefits to
wifey what happened but also but i
opened the door
that's all i see right there
on that so you've never met a girl that
you know you were not attracted to but
you're like oh this is a really cool
girl i want to be her friend like i want
to like you know play basketball with
her like play like you know whatever
or like you know drink some rum
and a blue moon type thing so what first
the first one i'll say to you is this um
you i think one of you mentioned because
you mentioned earlier on um
but you might you said you said maybe
someone have you mm-hmm and someone
might speak you might be attracted to
them because they may say things and do
things yeah difference what what
difference is this
as as men we're attracted to what we see
right we must have to what they hear
so i could tell sweet last women and
they fall for you even though i tried
you might be trying to see him he said
the right words and you you'll get you
yeah we don't that same thing doesn't
work with us we like what we see women's
fight or flaw
i do love me a good sweet talk
so far
if you get in mind right when you see a
woman yeah we're seeing them in pretty
much two different ways we will give
when most men all men give women
attention right because
you like it actually like giving
attention right
but what would the thing that
i'm gonna say all but i think when women
get confused they confuse
sexual attention with romantic attention
so that's because you give attention
doesn't mean that we like you just want
to [ __ ] you but like just different to
us want to wife you yeah but how would
we know because let's say how look let's
say you've got tinder a guy will only
swipe on you if he's attracted to you
and you go to your first date like very
quickly how do you know this person's
intent without being pushy that's really
difficult to find out because if a guy
okay it's only interested you sexually
first off the back how do you know
so i'm going to say something to you and
then answer your question so i'm going
to say first say
they think is stupid
they think we're stupid oh dating oh
dating isn't it so it serves no purpose
it's it's it's redundant doesn't make
any sense your grandpa your grandparents
they got married quickly had long
relationships dating doesn't work well
then why aren't you married
[Music]
what else have you been doing the last
15 years that's a difficult thing we
have done different books
dating is stupid dating is
yes but it serves no long-term purpose
okay
so when do you say what you want from a
guy well the question you say is
the question ask yourself is what you're
doing
are you dating for purpose
why are you dating what what what is
your end goal from day so i have to ask
this on the day so if i'm on a first
night what day why are you dating
somebody why are you going on dates what
is what do you want from dating to meet
someone alike
for what what for what what's it what's
the loss of end game
husband right so you then have to when
you meet a guy you have to be explicit
and say to say to him i'm dating to be
married
okay if he's not going to be married in
his ways you're wasting your [ __ ]
time
so like how would you know that from the
philippines
but you don't guess you don't assume
you meet him in a bar you meet him
online
i am only dating to be married if you're
not on this you waste some let's not
just not waste money but when you say
like that kind of like scary yeah that's
always gonna that's what you're gonna
say it scares a lot of us off but i
don't wanna be like married like now
like i'm saying like could be like four
to five years like that's the end game
[Music]
well every four to five years if you
don't if you're not say if you're not
explicit in your and what you want as an
outcome every time you meet somebody
you're just drifting along
you might not be around four or five
years so you wasted a year of someone
that was never interested in getting
married to anyone in the first place so
if you're not explicit about what you
expect as an outcome then how can the
outcomes you want you need to be say
right this is what i want
if you're not on this plan then there's
no point you join you know no point you
talk to me because this is what i want
at the end of it yeah but like guys in
the orders don't you think it's a bit
like a bit overbearing so on the first
date if someone says to like oh like i
want to get married and someone has to
kind of like gauge if they want to get
married
i didn't say to you i want to get
married i said to you i'm dating to be
mad i'm only dating to be married but i
think how can i marry you but i'm only
dating
that puts a lot of pressure no no but
you're what you're doing is filtering
the guys who have no intention of being
married i guess
i would say like even even mentioning
like the word married would freak him
out and it would freak me out if a guy
was like yeah i like i don't remember
what does dana go and he was like oh
like he was talking about like a
proposal like on the first date yeah it
really freaked me out
even though i was i had similar
intentions if you know what i mean i
would say like you know when the first
thing you would say like oh like i'm
trying to get in a relationship and then
you know maybe a few days later you can
be like oh like do you ever oh there we
go yeah yeah yeah yeah um
oh like you know are you maybe like
looking to get married but you wouldn't
say it on the first date yeah that's not
really a first date i don't think it's a
discussion
then i'm going to tell you both you're
very wrong and you're very flawed and
never
if that's what you want you're not going
to get what you want to laugh you're
going to go through life just drifting
but so i mean i'm telling you about
things
i think men also have autonomy in like
what's going on in the relationship and
i feel like a man just like okay because
the woman hasn't said
explicitly that she wants to get married
that it's off the table i think a man
should be able to also make that
decision as well so i feel like just
saying putting the whole thing in the
woman's hands is probably not fair you
missing something i'm not saying to you
you want to marry him i'm not saying
you're going to propose him